thank you for being here I the college
is well we're finishing in a few days
god grant our hundred and seventy fourth
year starting one hundred and seventy
fifth anniversary celebrations in
October we're gonna dedicate our grand
new Chapel which I urge you to come see
justice Thomas is gonna speak in
dedication of it on October 3 we're in
the exhausted part of the term right now
actually it just got better on Monday
cuz like last week and the week before
whatever friction and crankiness there
isn't a college comes out right at the
end we're all dragged down a week ago
those kids all look like members of the
cast of The Walking Dead and so they're
quarreling about this and that you know
and making a fuss and we tell them to
shut up but then Monday they all stop
because tomorrow's reading day and final
to start on Thursday and so now the
atmosphere is panic and I'm surprised
that Jim was willing to come down here
for that with all those kids cuz they
got to go home and work and because
we're not fooling around at Hillsdale
College I want to tell you something
that you know first of all can you tell
I love them
you know and all of them right you
should come see it
the greatest thing in the world is to
work with those young people and their
teachers and it is in fact the activity
that will save the world
its nature they come they look like
little kids
a lot of those are seniors it's probably
only about 6 music majors among that
group right there and there's 85 in the
orchestra and there's probably 10 that
are music majors and the rest of them do
it on the side and everybody has to take
the core and when they show up they're
high school students and when they leave
they're grownups
and they come into themselves and you
know these days we forget the massive
force of the nature of things
in fact we obscure it we make war on it
all the time I'm gonna talk about a
thing I read about tie what's going on
at Williams College it's disturbing
there's a smart man there I think he's a
big liberal I don't really care but he's
smart and he has studied that thing and
he's written it up and it is horrifying
it is the death of civilization so
thinking about that as we do at the end
of the academic year it seemed just
right that we could have somebody who is
I think on the radio the greatest
defender of civilization I've known him
for a very long time I admire him very
much
he's a scholar and a thinker and he
talks on the radio every day several
hours a day as long as I've known him he
stood up for that idea of nature and God
and the essence of the human and you
know all the time that I've known him
I've tried to do that too and mostly
we've been losing but I will tell you
that if he's right Thomas Jefferson is
also right you can drive the nature out
the front door with a pitchfork but it
will come in the back door before you
can even turn around
and the revival is coming and to help
with it as Dennis breaker
[Applause]
I came all the way from California to
have Larry Arne introduce me so I'll
just take questions now really I mean
that's a big deal usually people have to
wait for a funeral
and then they don't hear it so no I'm
very I'm very serious I'll be to uh to
get such a accolades from Larry Arnaz
he's to me a very big deal and obviously
to you because you know what he's doing
I know what he's doing as well we have a
sort of symbiotic relationship Hillsdale
and my radio show the major sponsor of
the show for which I am deeply grateful
and I push with great passion that
people learn about what happens at
Hillsdale Hillsdale dot e-d-u ask me
anything I I know the ads by heart by
now I know the courses I've had so many
of your professors on so if they were
listen they were a hundred hills dales
we'd have a different country that's
that's the fact
you know you spoke about the death of
civilization so I'm preparing I write a
column every week which is many many
sites on the Internet in addition to
obviously my own been for about twenty
years
and I'm going to be writing about
Philadelphia and its war on civilization
it just turns out to be coincidental but
it's when you can narrowly focus
something and I will just use that an
example and then I'll get into it's
really this is part of the topic but I
always speak about what I'm actually
asked to speak and the give you with
three examples of what is happening in
in Philadelphia I have some friends in
because I conduct as an avocation I
conduct orchestras I conducted at the
Walt Disney Concert Hall Hyden symphony
last year so I'm very involved in music
as an avocation so I follow a musical
life in the United States one of the
greatest orchestras in the world is the
Philadelphia Orchestra the Philadelphia
Orchestra has just held tryouts two for
the position of assistant conductor
500-plus people submitted conductors
submitted their resumes to be the
assistant conductor the Philadelphia
Orchestra is a big honor and they
finally chose and they chose a three
women and a black man and they had
already announced their their more
committed to diversity than anything
else there so they've they've also
announced they're going to play far more
women composers so what this means and
I'm prepared obviously I'm going on
record I know anything I say publicly is
heard publicly and may go further than
the room that's fine I I think we should
be held accountable for what we say
I don't believe that those three women
in that black man were the top four
candidates they may have been but I
don't believe it it has nothing to do
with my view of women let alone my view
of blacks it is simply very unlikely
given that the vast majority of those
applying were white males and they just
didn't want a white male and I know
members of the orchestra who know this
it's everybody knows it it's the Emperor
without clothes so what the one of the
greatest orchestras of the world has
announced it does not choose conductors
or leased assistant conductors by
excellence it chooses them by gender or
race that is the end of Western
civilization as we know it which is
entirely based on excellence that's the
only criterion if if it weren't I mean
I'm a Jew and I loved vogner's music
vogner was a racial anti-semite not just
the regular anti-semite but like Hitler
or race-based anti-semite but I I
believe that it is okay for the Israel
Philharmonic to play Wagner's music I
understand that they were Holocaust
survivors who associated music because
it was such a popular music under Hitler
and they have emotional reactions to
hearing it I get that but otherwise
beyond that specific issue it is an
homage same with the statues a Peter
Stuyvesant every every Jew knows and any
historian of early America knows Peter
Stuyvesant the first governor of
Manhattan was an anti-semite I don't
want his statue taken down because there
is no end there true and by the way
there is no end there will be no statues
except for contemporary black lesbian
poets and I and and and the reason I
raise that is is it is I have nothing
against black lesbian poets if their
poetry is excellent but the reason is
reason number two for Philadelphia the
University of Pennsylvania took down the
the English department which and it's an
Ivy League school for whatever that
means and to me it means nothing but I'm
just noting it and it they took down the
Department of English took down the
mural of Shakespeare and replaced it
with a black lesbian a poet whom the
very few people have heard of except in
the black lesbian poetry world which is
I don't know how big a world that is and
I'm not a member of it clearly but it's
nevertheless that is what they did
because he is a white European male the
fact that he wrote the greatest English
language and probably the greatest plays
in the history of the world since the
Japanese translated into Japanese and
Thais translated into Thai etc and that
but that doesn't matter so again this is
this is Philadelphia a third example was
Professor Amy wax University of
Pennsylvania Law School wrote a piece in
the Philadelphia Inquirer
where she said you know what some of the
values from the 50s really were good
like how about this that you should get
married before you have a child she was
called a racist for it 200 fellow
professors of law have demand that she
not be allowed to teach her introductory
course in law at the University of
Pennsylvania Law School 200 I didn't
even know there without many professors
of law at the law school 200 virtually
nobody defended her I had her on my show
a number of times look it up Amy wax and
the fourth example is the Philadelphia
Flyers I forget her name who was the the
the famous Kate Smith thank you
Philadelphia Flyers hockey team has
removed the the statue of Kate Smith the
great singer from the 30s who was always
they used her recording for god Bless
America but it came out that she sang a
song which by the way so did Paul
Robeson who was it was a left-wing
Stalinist and and I'm literally
Stalinist I got the Stalin prize in
Moscow well he didn't they didn't let
him go to Moscow but he was given it in
Moscow so this is this there is a war on
Western civilization and when
President of the United States said in
Warsaw that we need to protect Western
civilization the New York Times and
other left-wing sites used to be liberal
it's now left-wing I always make a
distinction between liberal left-wing
Allender she which is liberal and he
hates the left he fears the left more
than the right you will see him say that
in the film with Adam Carolla and myself
coming out later this year no safe
spaces so the this is what people stood
for in the past and we are no longer we
no longer affirm these values this is
this is a war when the president said we
have to protect Western civilization the
New York Times said that it was a dog
whistle two white supremacists that the
words protect Western civilization
really are a euphemism for protecting
white supremacy that is what Western
civilization means now at your local
university and high school I might add
and increasingly elementary schools so I
note by the way in a column that I wrote
about that that Dwight I act not the
right Eisenhower excuse me
that of Franklin Roosevelt who is the
the the great beloved president of
liberals he spoke regularly in World War
two not only protecting Western
civilization but Christian civilization
can you imagine if a president today
said protect Christian civilization and
I'm a religious Jew telling you I'm ok
with that
this Jew wants to protect Christian
civilization
all right just for the record
for if for no other reason what is the
alternative what is the alternative
Marxist Leninist civilization fascist
civilization communist civilization
secular civilization which produces no
wisdom no wisdom and just increasingly
produces what you have at the University
of Pennsylvania secularism almost
inevitably leads to leftism almost
inevitably not inevitably there are
secular conservatives after all they are
my allies they are my friends I treasure
them but they don't realize that America
is also based on in god we trust' which
i will come to in a moment the topic the
topic is that for me or god
just kidding by the way it's very funny
when I signed my Bible Commentary and
how often I'm prosign best wishes god
you have no idea it is a very funny
thing would you please sign the Bible
I'd be happy to sure or on behalf of God
Dennis Prager I I just there's so many
funny things that come to my mind but if
you get my book and want me to write on
behalf of God that is very difficult II
will so you assigned me American
greatness American culture and this is I
want to talk to you about America's
greatness so let me begin with a very
sad a realization that came to me not
immediately in life but I don't know
maybe just about halfway and I realized
actually the truth is not I think of it
I partially realized it very much
younger this is it seems irrelevant to
you when I realized it but it's not
completely irrelevant as I will explain
but the I realized this is the the
crisis of of America and the West and
Christianity and Judaism is that the
people who believed in it forgot how to
advocated that is in a nutshell we are
we are 50% of the problem the left is
50% we are the other 50% not 4950 the
average Christian has no clue how to
make the case for Christianity the
average American conservative has no
clue how to make the case for America
and the average religious Jew has no
clue how to make the case for Judaism
well when you don't make the case for
something you lose it when there are
alternatives when there aren't
alternatives you have it by inertia and
in the past there weren't alternatives
that's correct
religious Jew living in an Orthodox
Dental what was the alternative there
was none you kept kosher and you kept
the Sabbath and you kept the holy days
and you kept all the laws because
everybody else did you didn't have to
make any rational reason for living that
life Christian living in Christian
America everybody went to church on
Sunday it was socially one
full everything was nice I have to make
the case for why God is necessary for
ethics give me a break never it never
occurred to the average Christian that
they'd have to make such a case let
alone for Christianity specifically
Americans Americans totally forgot
what's distinctive about America and I
realize this as I said halfway through
life but I realized that actually
earlier not exactly directly I remember
I began lecturing a very strange life
truly strange life I began lecturing at
21 years of age which is pretty rare and
the reason was Israel sent me into the
Soviet Union when I was 21 years of age
they they found out about me through
friends in Israel it's a long story
which is irrelevant to you but they
found out that this kid knows Judaism
knows Russian which I studied in college
knows Hebrew which I studied from Jewish
school from early age and so I was the
perfect person to send in the Soviet
Union to smuggle in religious items and
smuggle out Jews names who want to do to
defect from the Soviet Union so I was
sent in for a month and I came home I
was at the Russian Institute at Columbia
University so I had quote-unquote an
academic credential and I was sent all
around the east and half of the country
to lecture on Soviet Jewry so I began a
very early age about three years after
that I called up a place that I had
spoken to and I said hi this is Dennis
Prager remember I was the speaker I was
24 years old now I was the speaker at
your Hadassah group it's a women's
Zionist group it was very big at the
time and I said you remember me I'm the
one who spoke on Soviet Jewry oh yeah
you were wonderful I said well I'd like
to come back and speak well we already
you know we've heard you want Soviet you
were said no no I want to speak on
something else and I'll never forget she
said you can speak on something else I
sort of had a reputation of an idiot
savant in in Jewish life where he you
know this is kids terrific but all he
can speak on a soviet jewry so I said
yeah I can't so anyways they so they I
told them what I could speak on anyway
so they said how much do you charge that
I remember I actually dripped sweat on
the phone I was so nervous asking for
money all those other speeches were for
free
so I said $35 it was a group in Queens I
was still living in New York and
Manhattan and so I was totally prepared
for her to say it was too much and I was
gonna lower it so I so she said fine and
then I said plus taxi which ended up
costing more than the speech the taxi
was actually more than the talk anyway
that was my first paid talk and I
remember what I started to tell because
my life until 32 was overwhelmingly in
the Jewish world and I'd written two
books on Judaism by that and I so I
remember telling them you know your
generation said we're gonna you're we
are going to give the next generation
that is my generation everything we
didn't have the trouble is you didn't
give my generation anything you did have
you didn't give us religion and you
didn't give us an appreciation of
America and a whole host I listed all
the things and then I broadened it out
when I broadened my own life out I
realized that is that was Universal in
America the greatest generation as it is
called and I think there were many great
American generations but let's utilize
that title was was the greatest
generation in terms of the the
Depression and World War two and Korea
but it was not the greatest generation
in what it produced it produced the most
narcissistic generation in American
history the baby boomers my generation
and the reason was that they in fact
gave what they didn't have money and
peace that's true but they didn't give
them a love of America or a love of
religion and the results are what you
see in America today the reason this is
also important therefore is that
you can lose everything in a generation
if you don't teach it to the next
generation therefore one of the greatest
lines in the Bible
is and you will teach these things
diligently to your children when you
walk by the way when you lie down and
when you rise up if you don't teach
these things constantly you will lose
them and we have lost them and it takes
one generation to lose it so it's funny
in the very beginning not only even the
beginning but many people would say to
me on about my radio show or then about
Prager University which had a billion
views last year so it really can't hold
true nevertheless say you know you're
probably preaching to the choir I always
had a really good answer to that
fine with me the choir forgot the melody
I'm totally happy to preach to the choir
because if the choir can sing it's over
and the choir doesn't know how to sing
the conservative choir the American
choir the Christian choir and the Jewish
choir don't have a clue how to sing I my
first radio experience talking about the
Christian issue my first radio
experience I was it was KABC in Los
Angeles ABC radio in LA I was there for
17 years and that's how I began radio
and I was asked to be the the host of
one of its it's truly most popular show
interesting news I already inherited a
popular show and it got even more
popular later when I was the moderator
for ten years and that was a two-hour
show each weekend religion on the line
we're in a rabbi priest and minister
they didn't go into a bar that came to a
radio station and different ones each
week and I I got four PhDs in
Christianity thanks to that show
this is Shiva boy learned Christianity
really really really well so well that
by year five on occasion I would
actually answer the attacker's of
Christians on behalf of the priests and
the minister by the way on occasions the
Christians helped out the Jew I'll give
you one great example my favorite
guy calls up calls the rabbi this was a
liberal rabbi in that that the evening
and calls him up and starts attacking
Jews for believing they're the chosen
people and I knew I knew my I know my
fellow Jews really well and I knew the
guy actually agreed with the caller this
guy believed in chosen is like I believe
in Pluto so but to his credit he felt he
was a representative of Judaism not just
himself so he tried to defend it he
didn't know how so the Catholic priest
then says Dennis may I may I answer the
caller I said father please because this
is father so-and-so that the Roman
Catholic priest God chose the Jews get a
life
[Laughter]
and that ended that doubt really the guy
had nothing to say he hung up and got a
life it was a great answer that's
exactly the right answer by the way cuz
the Bible gives zero reason why Abraham
is chosen we don't have a clue so that's
it he could if he chose a mongolians you
know why did he choose the mongolians
and it's same problem okay so it is what
it is so one night a guy calls up and he
starts giving the the Christians a hard
time I can't believe he you believe God
has a son oh my god honey you've got a
kind of primitive belief is that came to
earth died for our sins what the hell is
wrong with you you believe in some you
know magic in the sky so the poor
Christians you know not used to examine
exactly to answering that so I go may I
may I offer a thoughts so I said to the
caller look I'm a Jew I'm not I'm not a
believer in Christ but I gotta tell you
something it sounds to me like a pretty
powerful idea that God wanted to
identify with human suffering and came
in human form and suffered with us and
there was total silence and the guy had
no answer so this Jew gave the
Christians a good answer
just like that Catholic gave the Jew a
good answer but a lot of times nobody
has a good answer what's special about
America beats me
the average conservative didn't have an
answer people who died for this country
or who risk their lives I should say the
people who died can't speak they didn't
have an aunt well so why'd you risk your
life for America I love America I have
Allegiance maybe they'd say love Liberty
maybe I'd say I don't know I was drafted
but they they didn't have answers you
need answers you got to give reasons
meanwhile the left is giving all the
opposite answers America was founded by
racists built on genocide and Americans
don't know what to what to say to this
stuff we inhabit the greatest country
that was ever created and I don't say it
cuz I'm American I say it because I
believe in truth that's that's the
reason I'm not a chauvinist
I don't American isn't an ethnicity
there's no ethnic solidarity here but it
is the greatest country that was
ever created and and it is it is so
because of ideas give you a very
touching example and powerful example
about how this plays out I speak a lot
of college campuses so I spoke at
Berkeley last year and I knew there
would be protests because they protest
every conservative and so I don't care
about Pro that means nothing to me it
only means something to me if they don't
let me talk cuz they scream during the
speech which I have not had by the way
but I thought I might have it at
Berkeley so I said look I'll tell you
what I'm not gonna give a speech I'll
simply debate the two best left the
students you guys can find which I'm
very happy to do by the way
conservatives always win debates against
leftists always and there's a reason not
because we debate better because we know
every one of their arguments and they
know none of ours that's the reason we
always win we we read them we watch them
we hear them we study under them they
don't hear us they don't watch us they
don't study under us it is all new I
debated a left-wing Jew at a San
Francisco temple year ago and it was
I'm very courteous I and I'm very keen
on never humiliating anyone so I didn't
humiliate him but I defeated him I mean
I I know I did I know when I when I do
well I know when I don't so I I I won
the debate so to speak and I here's the
proof YouTube put it on it put it on its
restricted list
that's really that's awesome it's
actually funny half the remember they
putting half the time a man of the left
is speaking why would they put it on
because it was obvious the guy the guy
didn't look good he was not and he was a
bright guy he's a sweet guy all of these
things but he had no answers to anything
I said cuz he never heard anything I
said he's on the left every leftist
lives in a cocoon every single one if
they don't live in a cocoon they stop
being leftists the university the
university has become in the vast
majority of instances just a left-wing
seminary the only difference as I have
said frequently between University and
and the Christian seminary is this
there's only one difference and that is
the Christian seminaries are honest and
the universities are not Christian
seminaries acknowledged our task is to
produce committed Christians
universities lie to their parents
because their task is to produce
committed leftists and they don't admit
it that's why they are reprehensible if
they said the truth we have a lawsuit
Prager University because they put a
hundred of our 400 videos on YouTube
which is owned by Google on a restricted
list which means if you have filters
against pornography you can't see Victor
Davis Hanson teaching the history of the
Korean War in five minutes
all our videos are five minutes you
can't see Alan Dershowitz a Hillary
Clinton supporting Democrat liberal talk
about Israel's founding because anything
pro-american pro-israel is immediately
put on the restricted list at Google
YouTube so anyway so I said to Berkeley
oh I'm not gonna give a speech just have
two of your finest left-wing students
and we'll have a dialog debate they will
love the idea nobody heckled it was a
perfectly open evening you could see it
it is not on the restricted list maybe I
didn't win so but you'll judge for
yourself so I I have a motto on my radio
show which is so powerful that people
and I thought that I've told people you
should adopt it in your marriage it will
help marriages I prefer clarity to
agreement I do not argue with callers
and I do not argue with left-wing guests
I clarify where we differ it is
unbelievably powerful gets the other
person off the defensive all I want to
do is I want it I want to just say okay
so you think the earth is flat thank you
I just wanted to establish where we
differ
I think it's round okay fine so that's
what I did with the Berkeley students my
last question you could zoom to the end
I said to them do you believe people are
basically good human nature is good and
because they're leftist I knew exactly
what they would say yes it's part of the
reason you cannot be a wise leftist
because if you believe people are
basically good you cannot be wise it is
not possible I'm sorry if I offended any
of you I don't even care I just want you
to know you cannot be wise and think
people are basically good you certainly
can't be a committed Christian or Jew
and believe that so it's so stupid a
belief that there was only one possible
explanation and I said it to them I said
to them this do you know why you believe
people are basically good because you
live in America where people are for the
most part good America has fooled you
because it is so decent that's correct
by the way it is possible for people to
be good even if human nature is not good
obviously or the whole enterprise of
trying to make a good world is stupid of
course you could make good people but
that's the biggest task of society to
make good people that is what Judaism
and Christianity at their best are in
the business of doing making as they
used to put a god-fearing people anyway
so that's what I look they never heard
of course they
heard that idea you believe people are
by the way if I if you go to I've been
through a hundred and thirty countries I
ask people around the world you think
people are basically good they laugh at
me you think in West Africa they think
people are basically good of course they
don't because they know how much
corruption is in their societies this
has nothing to do with Africa it's true
all over the world
Americans are that other are among the
few to believe that people are basically
good because they're surrounded by good
people by and large like Minnesota nice
ok Minnesota nice now there's no such
thing as New York nice I acknowledge
that and and nobody in New York thinks
people are basically good they probably
don't actually anyway that was a
powerful moment about America's goodness
and decency when I explain to them
that's why you believe something so
foolish and I say to Jews in fact one of
the the biggest international Jewish
journals Jerusalem report my column I
they asked me for an article I never
wrote for them before I don't know where
they just asked me to write and I wrote
what have Jews this is the title what
Jews have learned what have Jews learned
from the Holocaust answer nothing most
Jews believe people are basically good
after Auschwitz that's really stupid
because people believe what they want to
believe for the most part anyway so this
is a very big deal Americans are decent
give you one more anecdote anecdotes are
powerful
well powerful anecdotes are powerful
we can octets are weak I want the
there's always a voice in me correcting
myself
so you're the beneficiaries of that self
correcting thing by the way you know why
I'm interesting I figured out why am i I
know I'm interested I were they just
thing I wouldn't make a living doing
what I'm doing alright it's not bragging
yeah you know you have to be interesting
like you have to pay on pitch if you're
a violinist but I realize why I just
because I have this voice would be
that's outside of me and I remember in
my first lectures and I began lecturing
as I told you at 21 in what lecture I'll
never forget that this other voice in me
said you're boring me I'll never forget
it as long as I live I was boring me and
I thought holy crow this is bad if I'm
boring me how are they surviving so I
got interesting right after that because
I get bored so easily it's a blessing
that I get bored easily you're the
beneficiary of it so here's an
interesting anecdote I wrote on this too
it's in it's a column that I wrote when
I moved to LA where after fleeing New
York there were those who moved from New
York I fled New York
so after moved from New York to Los
Angeles in my 20s and the 70s I so I
moved there and I I moved to a place a
call which now you heard of but was then
unknown Simi Valley California outside
of LA and it was basically it had it had
one pizzeria that was it it was it was
nothing and I did it because I was
brought out through to be the director
of this gigantic 3200 square acre or
3200 acre Jewish retreat center which
was located in Simi Valley so that's why
that's why I moved there and I lived at
this place for three years in Simi
Valley
I immediately joined the Rotary Club I
was about 25 years old yeah 26 years old
and I joined the Rotary Club I was the
only Jew in the semi Valley Rotary Club
and I wrote about this it's online you
could read it it's a I think it's an
interesting article this was
transformative for me in in my my
falling in love with America I fell in
love with America I didn't start out in
love with America just like most people
my generation
because we weren't taught to love
America but I fell in love with America
and the Simi Valley Rotary Club is one
of the reasons what was fair I knew
Jewish history really well I'd already
written a book on Judaism and I taught
Jewish history at Brooklyn College City
University of New York so this this is I
have a strong background in that and I I
was I marveled at the fact that my being
a Jew in in a in the semi Valley Rotary
Club ready meant nothing and nothing
I was Dennis not Dennis the Jew in
France
it would have been Dennis the Jew danila
Sharif in Holland it would have been
Dennis the Jew in England it would have
been Dennis the Jew in every country on
Earth that doesn't mean they're
anti-semitic no no no I'm not charging
them with anti-semitism I'm charging
them with differentiation whereas we
don't it meant nothing and they all knew
I was the head of the Jewish retreat
center they they all knew it maybe
Dennis isn't a Jewish name but there
were Jewish retreat center it was a
Jewish retreat center they all knew I
was Jewish it didn't mean anything it
wasn't good it wasn't bad it was a
non-issue and if a black joined it would
have been a non-issue and if I'm
Armenian joined it would have been a
non-issue and then and if it Albania
enjoined or a Japanese join it's a
non-issue the left makes it an issue
because they are truly racist but for
the conservative American it means
nothing
who are you having opening at Hillsdale
Larry aren't mentioned it who are you
having opening your your new chapel by
golly the man is black that must be
shattering kind of concern out of the
conceal faith when they see him I've
asked conservative groups of a thousand
and more I've asked them this question
so here's your choice for the Supreme
Court nine white male Christian
liberals or nine black lesbian
conservatives you're laughing because we
all know exactly how we'd all vote give
us the black lesbians Eddie day we're
thrilled with them cuz we don't care
they care we care about your values he's
one of the greatest Supreme Court
justices in American history period
that's why you're having him he deserves
to be honored he's a magnificent human
being and a magnificent judge and that's
all that matters to us there the racist
everything is backwards in the u.s.
we're not the racist which brings me to
another part of America's greatness we
are the least racist multiracial country
in human history there is nothing close
to the United States and their left I
wrote about this and I again it's a
column when you write twenty years of
columns a lot of columns out there and I
wrote this at a column the greatest
libel since the medieval blood libel let
me tell you about the medieval blood
libel for a second Jews were killed on
mass and expelled from England because
of it in in the 15th century I believe
it was or 13th century 14th century and
that was the charge that arose that Jews
slaughtered Christian children for their
blood to bake matzah on Passover which
is it's known as the blood libel because
and by the way it was actually it had an
interesting effect on Jews and I know
this as I said I told you which history
in college level it had a very
interesting effect because when you're
hated a lot you start to think maybe the
haters are right people just think that
if everybody around you says X Y or Z
maybe some of it is true but every Jew
know knew this was the greatest lie that
they could possibly hear Jews have been
prohibited from animal blood from any
blood since the book of Genesis it is
one of the things God instructs the
human race in fact even non-jews
according to the Bible should not be
eating the blood of animals
so they all-news a lie and that said
uh-oh maybe they just are liars and and
it had at least and had that salutary
effect the second biggest lie in my
history and as I know I wrote is that
America's racist that is how big a lie I
consider it is and Akala me on America
like it was a calla me on Jews to say
that they slaughtered Christian children
for their blood there was there was no
truth to the first and there was no
truth to the second are they're racists
of course they're a racist so what so
what that doesn't mean anything there is
everything in America that's like saying
if you periodically get a cold you're
sick if you get a cold and I ask you are
you sickly you would say no I just have
a cold it'll get over and I'm back yes
the the racist in America are like a
cold that they exist but they don't
define the body the body is not racist
that is America it is truly on racist so
why does the left call America racist
well it does so because it hates America
liberals do not hate America leftist do
and and that's that's a very important I
make this distinction liberal left all
the time liberals give you a great
example
liberal started the Superman comic
liberal Jews invented Superman Superman
was as patriotic and American loving why
don't remember truth justice and the
American Way that was the motto of
Superman
it was Jewish liberals in the 30s who
invented him Jewish leftists ten years
ago were the new writers and owners of
Superman
they had Superman stand in front of the
UN and renounce his American citizenship
he is no longer an American he is now a
citizen of the world that is the
difference one of the many between
liberal and left liberals did love
America leftists loathe America all the
world's left this love by the way this
proof I have the simplest proof if
people think oh that's not fair to say
leftist hate America left this do hate
America I'll give you a proof not an
argument
they're that they're different Barack
Obama who's a leftist not a liberal
Barack Obama said for five days before
his election in 2008 to a cheering crowd
I am I am depressed to say he said we
are five days away from fundamentally
transforming the United States of
America so let me ask you a question if
you met a man and said how do you feel
about your wife private conversation you
know I I would really like to
fundamentally transform her just out of
curiosity clever you it is not possible
to say you love something you wish to
fundamentally transform it it's not
possible I love my husband but I want to
fundamentally transform him then you
don't love him you love what you can
imagine him being under the fundamental
transformation you wish to see come
about they don't love America they love
some vision of a fundamentally
transformed place that's different
liberals did love America so what they
do is this what they what they do is
when they say America's racist they they
do so a because they they just hate it
that's that's one reason but there's an
and there's another reason there is a
childish aspect to leftism
it's a it's an immature mode of thought
and one of the ways is you compare the
reality to utopia like John Lennon's
Imagine that's all leftists they're
always imagining and they even use the
word like I have to imagine a a with a
place with no racism and no sexism and
we're we're men will
strong and powerful but not toxically
masculine none toxically masculine and
they will only see women as fellow human
beings never sexually but of course if
you meet such a man there's something
wrong with him okay or he's gay in which
case there's nothing wrong with him but
it's old those are the only two
possibilities if he's heterosexual there
is something wrong with him
because gay men see men in sexual terms
the only difference between gay men and
straight men is the object of their
desire but the the the essence is the
same
they see what they want in sexual terms
that's the way it is we have to grow up
but what you're taught if a man sees a
woman like that oh my god then he can't
respect her what are you talking about
who made up such a stupid line what do
you think you really think we're stupid
we can't see you at sexual terms and
respect you at the same time that's
worse than walking and chewing gum at
the same time I mean it is so easy to do
you have no idea hello I do it all the
time just Kay my doctor is very cute but
I did not choose her for her cutit ood I
chose her for her medical knowledge so I
can balance the fact that she's cute and
I see her in sexual terms and the fact
that I go to her because she's such a
good doctor
isn't that amazing the juggling that my
mind my male brain has been able to
achieve
mind boggling so this is childish aspect
so why is America racist because they
hate it and because there are three
reasons because they hate it because
they want the black vote every happy
black is Republican every grateful black
any black who says I'm grateful to be
American votes Republican so you have to
make sure blacks are not grateful to be
American but actually have contempt for
America then yet they stay Democrat it
is a disgusting disgusting and
unbelievably destructive thing to
America and to blacks to raise children
to think that whites hate you is so it
is truly a form of child abuse and the
third is they compare America not to
other countries but to utopia all
leftism his utopian all that's why their
children children believe in utopia
adults don't I walk around amazed at how
good America is not disgusted at how bad
American is that's why I'm not on the
Left that defines the difference in a
second I know other countries not only
because I was at a hundred and thirty
countries though that helps but because
I read history this place is amazing
it is amazing it is so none not non
xenophobic it's people come here and
they blend in if you want to blend in
you blend in nobody's telling you I live
in an area I work in it specifically in
an area Glendale California which has
more Armenians than any city on earth
outside of Yerevan the capital of
Armenia alright
I mean hey after people you bump into
are Armenian and they I have zero
problem with their sending their kids to
Armenian schools learning Armenian
language I would said to a Jewish school
I speak Hebrew fluently I learned my
Bible they learn their Bible I think
it's great but they become American like
I became an American I was taught how
lucky I was in Maya Sheva to be American
I was taught it where with George
Washington plays when they were still
George Washington's birthday some of you
or all of you over 40 or 45 perhaps know
the date of George Washington's birthday
no one under 40 knows his birthday
Presidents Day yes
honoring Franklin Pierce no offense no
offense sure he's a sweet good man his
wife loved them I don't know what damn
thing about Franklin Pierce
but if you say Presidents Day now might
as well be Franklin Pierce they're all
the presidents they've compared America
not to other countries but to a utopian
vision where all men have no toxic
masculinity where there is no difference
between male and female
where there is everybody loves everyone
and life unconditionally
don't start me next time you have me if
you want I'll just do a 35-minute attack
on unconditional love a term which has
no basis in Judaism or Christianity none
even though many Christians believe in
it many Jews do too but for different
reasons and by the way if you look GU
GLE has a very interesting chart the use
of terms since 1900 until today
unconditional love was never used before
1950 and from 1960 to today it has
skyrocketed in its references in
literature unconditional love which is
in it but that's that's that's a big
thing that's what they imagined there
will be a world in which you don't earn
love I'm a believer in earning love okay
my favorite verb in English is not love
my favorite verb in English is earned
the best word that exists any kid who
grows up believing he has to earn
everything will be a better human being
that's how you produce good human beings
you've got to earn your money you've got
earn admiration you've got to earn a
trophy you've got to earn an award
you've got to earn happiness earn is a
conservative word and by the way it's
almost uniquely English very few
languages have the word earned in
Spanish and in and in and I know I know
French
so French its gun a Gagne means to win
it is very different or a gun got the
gun yah I think it is organ our right
this what is to swim in Spanish huh
Naggar is gun our ganar right so it
means it means to win winning an income
is very different from earning an income
winning is luck earning is deserved big
difference we earn not win
so they compare America to to utopia
then it stinks I agree compared to
utopia America is is sick Serb sexist
intolerant xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist and bigoted that is
correct that is what it is so I've said
it so often I have it down to an acronym
oh but there are there many more since
then transphobic there's a whole host of
phobias by the way you'd never notice
there's no krysta phobic nobody hates
Christians isn't that awesome the most
murdered group on earth today for its
religious convictions but there's no
hatred term for it byxis the left owns
language how God is anti-semites as
anti-semitic there's Islamophobic
there's no krysta phobic that amazing
the scum who slaughtered almost 300 to
Christians in Sri Lanka on Easter by the
way they didn't rebound the truth is
according to the left they really didn't
kill Christians they killed Easter
worshippers right for all those of you
who worship Easter I'm sure you're
related to it immediately
this is the world we live in I could do
this for hours because it's endless it
is endless the assault on truth that
that we have the American Trinity is
unique and that is another reason for
its greatness it is a big reason I told
you conservatives don't know how to
explain America to their kids so I have
I have a great formula for you and it is
that we have a Trinity just like
Christianity has a Trinity American
Trinity I didn't invent it's on every
coin liberty and god we trust'
a plural cinema there's no other country
in the world that has those three that
is unique to America Liberty that's
unique to America limited government is
a unique there is no other not Canada no
one the United States alone had was
founded on the belief of limited
government for and this is one of my
mottos we even have a bumper sticker
that has this phrase the bigger the
government the small or the citizen we
want the citizen big and the government
little that is our that is what we stand
for
because the citizen is created in God's
image the government isn't big
difference so we are for liberty the
rest of the world is for equality
Liberty is a value never ever think
people yearn to be free they do not they
yearn to be taken care of and where did
I learn that in the book that taught me
most of the wisdom that I have the Bible
which is why I'm writing the rationale
Bible
I have no compunctions about telling you
to buy it for the following reason and
that is no one writes Bible commentaries
to get rich is that fair are we on the
same page on that one
oh the guy's a millionaire he wrote a
commentary on Leviticus no kidding oh
there's a there's a pot of gold or at
the end of that rainbow why didn't I
think of that
Genesis is coming out next week Exodus
came out last year these this is my
lifetime of teaching from the Hebrew for
people of every background read the
reviews on Amazon you'll see it does
touch lives it's called a rational Bible
and I'll give you an one of the many
examples of life transforming ideas the
Israelites are freed by God himself
right
splitsies 10 plagues amazing stuff takes
place and within within weeks they are
in the wilderness fed every day by the
way perfectly well fed by manna from
heaven or from Earth but manna and sure
enough what do they say they say let's
go back to Egypt better in Egypt because
the food was better that is what they
say in the Bible by the way the one of
the reasons I believe that the the that
at least the first five books I which
have a special status in Judaism and
Christianity known as the Torah and our
divine is that the Jews had depicted so
negatively if Jews wrote it and not a
divine hand they never would have
depicted themselves so awfully
no no I'm totally convinced i-it's
actually one of the most persuasive
arguments I have for the nonhuman
authorship of those books and and anyway
the Jews look like jerks but they're not
jerks they're normal people rather be
slaves who were well fed than free
people who have boring food and they
were well fed it was just boring manna
manna manna manna but hey we had meat
back in Egypt so why do I learn I learn
a truism about human nature people don't
yearn to be free people yearn to be
taken care of that's the left the left
one of the reasons it's so popular the
left all over the world is it it
corresponds to human nature that's why
Liberty is a value not an instinct
that's the key this country's founded on
values not instincts a pluribus unum
from anyone we don't give a hoot where
you're from what you look like that's
not to say Americans never did or no
Americans did of course we had racism
obviously but the the value is we don't
care we violated our own values okay
simple as that but we had the value that
is the value from anyone and now what
the left is doing is from many many
black dorms all over the country black
dorms George Wallace wanted black dorms
the racist Governor of Alabama wanted
black dorms and now the left wads
Blackthorn's it's mind-blowing black
graduation that that Harvard black
graduation that's disgusting a pluribus
unum and in god we trust' because you
can only have small government if you
have a big God Jefferson knew that and
he was no a devout Christian Franklin
knew it and he was no devout Christian
every one of the founders knew it you
either have big God or big government
this stuff hasn't been taught to the
next generation this is all news is new
to most of you and you're committed
conservatives I don't blame you if you
haven't been taught it how you supposed
to know it that's why I feel such a if
you will a missionary zeal
to get the word about America out while
I still have time on this earth because
once you understand that it goes oh my
god that now I get it now I know why In
God We Trust if Europe if you are an
atheist conservative you should value in
god we trust'
because ultimately if God dies
government grows that's the way it works
like in Europe people have to be
accountable to something and unless you
were fool it can't just be to their own
conscience so it's either gonna be to
the police and the state or it's going
to be to the God of the Ten Commandments
the God who said love your neighbor as
yourself
the judeo-christian conception of God
from the Bible so that's it that's that
is America
and if nothing else you now understand
this trajectory in my in this just this
one individuals life I have fallen in
love with this country
I am truly the opposite of the leftist I
just want to improve it but I don't want
to fundamentally transform it thank you
very much thank you so much thank you
thank you everybody thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all a very kind it's very
sweet appreciate it a lot I earned that
because and I'll tell you how I know
because you didn't start with one a lot
of places I thought so I got a standing
ovation when I begin and I go I can't do
any better this is terrible
I can only disappoint them so this was a
better feeling you know you started out
to get me a polite applause where like
you showed up but did the end so I felt
you got to earn earn is the best feeling
there is that's why we didn't teach kids
either that's what's why that's why
entitlements are so horrible it's
degrading to the recipient it's so
terrible so and by the way I do have a
belief I truly believe and I never
exaggerate I took a vow 35 years ago
when I began a radio not just never to
lie that's a given not to exaggerate
I believe this literally I think it is
harder to get off addiction to
entitlements than it is addiction to
heroin that's how bad it is the the
Democrats and the and the left are drug
pushers they're drug dealers with
benefits and they should be regarded as
such they are indistinguishable from
drug dealers in the harm they do to the
recipients do some people need need
government handouts yes some people need
some equivalent to heroin like in and
opioid absolutely and they should be
given it no question just as some people
should get the entitlements but the vast
majority live you get free lunch and
free breakfast and when they did the
vectra's I announced on my radio show
when I have a big LA audience I said any
parent who cannot give their kid
breakfast is a defective parent period
there was something wrong with them as
parents and of issue I am NOT going to
facilitate such Parenthood how much is a
an egg McMuffin seriously I'm not joking
how much is it huh what
Oh three hours and 58 cents and it's
damn nutritious I'm not joking
egg I'm Pro egg by the way there's
nothing wrong with eggs don't give me a
break please alright alright let's go -
where's yeah and we have people coming
up mics we we have time for a couple
questions please raise your hand and
wait for the microphone to be brought to
you there's one back there and one right
how many microphones do we have - all
right it may take five minutes to get to
over there but that's fine I don't have
a problem I'll tell you what I think
about hiding mall Arena and are we okay
as there it is that's a different time
zone that's that area is Larry it seems
to me that there is a vicious war going
on between those who want to attack
traditional culture and those who want
to defend it
such as Hillsdale College for me
traditional culture has six aspects
faith marriage family
individual responsibility work ethic and
patriotism each of these values is
viciously attacked if the other side
wins what I'm going to have a whatever
attitude what do you think I review yes
I love those six I I just want to say
what will happen I'll tell you what will
happen the I have finally come to
realize and it was only thanks to my
finishing my Genesis commentary well I
wrote a book explaining leftism
Americanism and and Islamism it's called
still the best hope and I pointed out if
you ask a Christian give me the book
that essentially describes what you
believe say here's the Bible is that
fair okay there's more obviously there's
so much great theology but that's
basically it if you ask a Jew is the
Bible maybe the Talmud as well but fine
ask a Muslim here's the Quran and the
hadith ask a leftist how do i what give
me a book so I'll know what you believe
they have no answer
so it's not a Karl Marx right yeah the
number of left to suit read Karl Marx is
is equal to the I'm trying to think of
something scarce the number of delta
smelt that I raise in my home aquarium
if you don't know about the delta smelt
you're lucky but anyway it's an
endangered fish that is the size of your
finger a half your finger for which
reason there is a lack of water in the
Central Valley in California okay but
it's okay so anyway I realized something
it took me till this last commentary
what did God do the six days of creation
I don't care whether you believe 24
hours or not it's not my point but the
six days of creation what a God do we
think create well as it happens the word
create has only used three times God
made a lot created a lot what God mostly
did is make order by making separations
between for example of course day and
night light and darkness human and God a
human and an animal male and female it
is and and remember Genesis 1 is in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the earth Genesis 1:2 is and the earth
was and the Hebrew Toba Volvo who is not
fully explicable but essentially means
chaotic God spent the six days of
creation making order out of chaos chaos
is the natural state the left wishes to
reinstate the chaos that's why there's
no book describing their beliefs because
they're that they don't even know what
they are if you would have asked the
leftist 15 years ago are men men and
women women or so are you nuts of course
so how did they change their minds that
there's no such thing as men and women
and you allow male bodies to run against
female bodies in Connecticut high school
girls races and win and then say well
women want women won given as male
bodies that one
whether they call themselves women or
not they or male bodies that's a fact
that's not an opinion that's not
transphobic it's real it's reality they
are for chaos the the male/female issue
is perfect example of chaos that's what
they represent there the for God the
judeo-christian world that we inhabit or
inhabited represents order divine order
they hate the concept of divine order
they hate it that's part of the reason
they hate judeo-christian values and
Jews and Christians who uphold it we
represent the opposite of what they
believe in and they're right they know
better that we do how opposed the two
are they are a force of chaos you asked
what will happen chaos will happen and
chaos brings order but not the divine
order man's order and man's order is
evil you'll get order after the leftist
chaos in in it like the Nazis brought
order that's the order you'll get
anybody else on that happy note we have
time for one more question by the way
yeah it's hard for you to believe I'll
bet I wrote a book on happiness but when
I tell you the title now you'll believe
me happiness is a serious problem that's
the title their their belief in entropy
yes but they wouldn't acknowledge it yes
this is the last question ok oh oh so
where is the question there you are how
you doing we talked about leftist and
they're investigating Trump on all this
money stuff and all that why isn't
anyone said one word about the drug
cartels that are spending millions and
billions of dollars and the Democrats
are probably getting this money we need
to investigate that because they don't
they want open borders and they're
getting part of this money I don't care
what anyone says that money's coming
from drug money and they're ok they're
using
I am all for investigating the Democrats
but I want to answer the the the first
part on on tax returns I said from the
beginning of my radio career began in 82
I said I am totally opposed to
politicians having to give their their
tax returns to the public it is none of
my damn business about this person's
income it is none of my business and
what it does you see it's it's all fake
the whole world of the left is fake so I
have a few questions
did anybody learn anything important
about any candidate democrat or
republican because of tax returns of
course not zero nada nothing you learn
nothing all we do is humiliate people
who run for office and they that left
arm our masters of humiliation that is
what they do best look at what they did
to judge Cavanaugh they only know how to
humiliate humiliation is an art on the
Left if it we we strip people naked to
run for president of the United States
and by the way it's a whole things of
fraud if it's important to know the tax
returns before we elect a president why
isn't it important to know them before
we elect a senator or a congressman or a
governor and by the way if it's
important that we know that why is it
important that we not we not we not know
or no not know I guess the the tax
returns of the editors of the New York
Times they have more power in this
country than any senator does they have
more influence I want to see the tax
returns if that's what they want to do
then that's then then everybody has to
reveal them it all it does is prevent a
lot of people from running for office
you know that to run for office is to be
humiliated now if you're willing to be
humiliated especially if you're a
Republican that's fine I have no desire
to know one you know how I learned this
this is this is I learned this from my
father may he rest in peace
who was my accountant he was a CPA was
my my account somebody was 90 he retired
at 90 smoked his last cigar in 96 which
is my aim and by the way just just on
that note and then I'll tell you about
my father accountant so this was great
Dallas Morning News about a year ago had
an article on the oldest living World
War one veteran I believe it was a black
soldier living in Texas he was a hundred
and seven is that possible without a
would he have qualified for yeah he
would maybe would have yeah because
World War one ended in 1918 so 100 now
couldn't have been couldn't have been
World War one
anyway the oldest living something
couldn't it certainly was in World War
two obviously but anyway he's babies
just the oldest living veteran how's
that yeah I think I got it alright
nothing like thinking aloud in front of
600 people okay so the guy was
interviewed he's a hundred seven hundred
ten whatever he was so of course they
asked him the everybody asked the same
question what's your secret so the guy
gave an answer and he became my instant
hero he said that the secret to living
this long is God and cigars and I
thought holy crow this is my it's my
prophet this man is a prophet in my life
god that's me God in cigars
i I can't get over it so anyway my
father smoked the cigars until 96 but he
was a count until 90 so in his heyday I
remember when I was a kid and living at
home he would talk about his work and he
had a very interesting thing which I
never I put two and two together later
he said you know why I love my work boys
to my brother and me you know why I love
my work and frankly I didn't because I
have I never thought for a minute of
being an accountant so I didn't know why
he loved his work he said I'll tell you
why I love my work first I love making
sure that people legally pay Uncle Sam
as little as possible which immediately
even as a kid I thought he was a great
man so
the the other the other but he said
there's another reason he said once you
know a person's financial records they
believe they can open up about anything
and I am NOT just their accountant I'm
their psychiatrist they tell me about
their sex life with their lives because
the most people are more willing to talk
about that than their finances how much
do you earn is such a secret in society
people don't ask their best friends how
much do you earn but they may talk about
problems in their marriage or with their
kids which you would think are far more
shameful or or embarrassing or whatever
for whatever reason that is considered
to be something we allow people to have
privacy with regard to I don't believe I
have a right to know everything about
anyone that's just wrong
it's just morally wrong and it's there's
no wisdom to it I know nothing about you
if I say if I see your tax return so I
see how much charity you gave ok so
here's here's a fact I give charity but
I also give I give a lot of money to
people in my synagogue who have no money
that's not tax deductible because
they're not an official charity that's
not on there what about the people who
take care of their parents
and their whole life is spent they don't
they don't have an official charity
return do you know how good they are
we know nothing from your tax return
nothing I don't want to know it but
who's gonna say that I don't want to
know it the press that wants to run the
country wants to know everything and for
the left humiliating people is an art
that's why I salute this president it's
one of about a hundred reasons I salute
this president because he does have
he has and with this I will end he has
the rarest of all the good traits
there's kindness there's loyalty there's
integrity there's all sorts of many
wonderful good traits but the most
important of all is courage and he's got
that thank you all very much
[Applause]